how you doing Theo just come in here and
and completely take your spot hey this
is hey did he just wait he's not booked
today oh no he's booked tomorrow and he
just walked in like five minutes before
you tried to [ __ ] alpha-male your
spot we didn't like it yeah that's
bird's mouth on that man he already has
the disease so probably now you have
wait was wet and you put it on your
mouth I didn't put it on my it came on
top with this yeah it's not fair cause
you put the ears on and then this kind
of comes into your mouth hands on your
ears birthstone I just found out due to
Roxy's astute questioning that Jim was
with two women just last night were you
really do not at the same time so what
type of separation are we talking in
terms of hours minutes a couple hours
couple hours separated yeah did you get
with just oral sex oh wow that's I mean
legally that sex I liked it I liked the
Jim is like he's mature enough that
rocks he goes like what base did you get
to and Jim's like I have [ __ ] blown
okay I did sexual activities
he did adult sexual activity he's an
adult sexual activities to me in sex if
you just putting it out there like that
all the time then you know guys aren't
gonna stick around for it sexual
activities and Roxy's like there's not
many steps before it like witters blunt
being blah to women yesterday not me
did you clean before did you wash it
between we can wash the washing between
not before during or after he got off a
plane he got blown by a couple chips I'm
sorry but showering and you actually
these do you feel a little bit kind of
um you know exhausted today from it one
day is a lot yeah I haven't slept a
little I've slept three hours and like
two and a half days
that's yeah well but you're very good to
get him blown did you sleep in a bed
yeah where where else do you think he
might sleep it's Jim Norton you know I
guess you might ask the question no
you're right I spent every morning with
him sometimes I think things for granted
you should not be assuming things when
you walk in the door is to see the
pictures that you guys post on your on
your show Instagram and it's always my
papers all right baby let's do it let's
knock one out of the park and Jim Jim
guys he's got his roots of phyto he
pulled over his head just slumped over
he's racing crows and it's hard to read
the morning but you do great you do
great I like to read the paper you do
eat the paper the paper read the paper
see oh are you a single man right now I
am man I like to just have been going
through some of that kind of stuff man I
struggle a lot with that kind of stuff
what kind of stuff getting blown twice
oh oh that sounds like what honest what
am i worth having to come twice in one
day is one of my worst night I don't do
that very often use if I do it's usually
one time I'm jerking both times and the
second time my dick is just limp and
gives in when was the last time you came
twice in one day this week outside from
yesterday yes self abuse right are you
going through some [ __ ] right now you
got to push through the dark huh you're
just pulling through the dark tug
through the darkness he's tugging
himself dick first through the darkness
it happens and I did something why I
came one time and it was real cold when
it came out and that scared me that's
not nothing that's not good at all did
you a doctor mm-hmm didn't didn't
persist nope one time Wow when are we
talking I think it was that that I've
been on an airplane too so maybe it had
something to do with that it sounds like
you had a magic load yeah like in that
one moment now sure if it was going out
with gold it was cold
yes I said if it was cold coming out
that's so not usual if it was gold
coming out live at night of course I'm
getting a job on the Kardashian estate
market in a bird by I jerk off in gold
want to acquire my services but no I you
know it's hard out there dating these
days and us it's tough I think
especially in LA it's a lot of just why
it's lonely greedy weirdos out here yeah
this place is starting to fester on
itself it's getting kind of sad it is
right yeah I'm very bad with
relationships too I date sperm little
periods inspirati it's really it's hard
to maintain anything well do you think
that you also suffer from wanting what
you don't have meaning when you're not
in a relationship but I have access to
plenty of floozies you want to go out to
dinner you want to have the nice
relationships but once you have the nice
relationship you're just looking for
filthy trash that you can own your dick
in no I'm telling you man I would mind
it at this point
Wow yeah I wouldn't mind it at this
point yeah just a nice whatever
relationship I'm not gonna settle for
701 but yeah right you hear that Roxy I
do hope you taking notes lookit see you
doing that actually man if I you know
settling down a willy loman type of
thing yeah yeah just settling down ya
know nice gal yeah but you have to find
somebody they can put up with your
antics right someone open-minded you're
[ __ ] crazy person is I don't think
you're basically a clique that looks
like a shape and Bert Kreischer [ __ ]
butt plugs there's yellow toys
oh yeah kazoos a yellow toy that looks
like a movie minions yeah stripped of
the overalls
yeah that's jaundice first of all and it
sound like kidney failure
I gotta tell you something my kid is in
a phase right now where he's watching a
lot of the minions I can't watch that
movie anymore without thinking it's a
bunch of butt plugs dancing or coming
over I know testing hard on sad it's a
good movie I think you like that minions
I didn't like the Derwin I see why you
watch children's movies I like some of
them yeah I'm better you don't have a
little bit of realism in them you know
they don't you know you you like up yeah
do you like the sad part or just get
through the sad part the whole thing sad
with the beginnings really the sad part
he finds that she's got Barren womb yeah
and the house gets repossessed it is
like a balloon payment or something
wanna bring up the thing the house is
repossessed they take all the furniture
out just like that beginning part two
you like the whole thing I like
children's films do you don't have
children yourself no I don't so what do
you woody what is it what is the
pleasure that you get out of children's
films I think it just makes me not have
to like you know just make it makes me
be you know it's easy for me to enjoy
thinking I don't have to a little
escapism maybe caught up and a lot of
it's better I mean the movies these days
are garbage bro done Kirk's the only
good movie I've seen any since Dallas
buyers club I didn't love Dunkirk
but I'll be honest the Meg really had me
is it but you know the giant shark was
terrible
oh yeah it sound bad I watched oceans 8
on the plane watching those what you
know 11 except with a bunch of chicks
well there was no I don't know if
they're being protective of the women
because they really wanted him to look
like heroes they really wanted it to be
empowering there was no you know in
Ocean's eleven I like Ocean's eleven I
don't like Ocean's Twelve and I like
Ocean's thirteen because there's they're
outsmarting somebody they gotta break
into a casino there's either it's Andy
Garcia or it's Al Pacino and these are
super smart guys that are watching their
every move and somehow they got to get
around it and do all these schemes and
it's amazing there wasn't anybody for
these chicks to outsmart in this movie
no they were just stealing a necklace
you know and so without that foil yeah
without that person there for them to
outsmart I said I'm not overly impressed
by these women
gutter bro it is gutter it's just
forstman ever since black auntie movies
at
[ __ ] I think black nanny killed it for
you so jay-z white people Evert nobody
likes black Annie I didn't see it yeah
it wasn't a popular this was called
Annie but not really if you talk to
people you know cuz if they would come
in here and said films have been [ __ ]
since Annie yeah I'd be like that's
that's decades like Daddy Warbucks
you know exactly it's just like movies
if you just got mad you know I feel like
that but also television tell me what's
gotten so good television is amazing you
see a lot of movies though yeah I try
but it's just really you know I just
felt like it I just don't get my money's
worth anymore I don't know what it is
man
a lot of them are just bet even what I
don't like it's a lot of the acclaimed
ones used to be I felt like kind of and
the acclaimed ones just don't do it for
me you know three signs whatever that
was called three bill it was one hidden
camera to rest here would have made that
film twice as good exactly my wife was
so upset with me cuz she walked out like
Oh what did she think and I was like
honey it was terrible
yeah it was for doorman good she's
basically Robert Duvall in a wig and we
all know that that's right I like her I
love Bob Duvall Sam Rockwell is good
that's great all these actors are good
but the movie sucked you know I gotta
force [ __ ] kind of weird racism they
try to tie in all the problems of the
afternoon who's the cop some white guy
did something wrong but they go like
like a guy a cop throws a guy out the
window yeah and like yeah either he
kills him or injures him very very badly
and his punishment is well you can't be
on the force anymore and you're going
like what that no cop is throwing
anybody I don't window use not my
audition tomorrow smart you're gonna
calm and really yeah I'm auditioning
yeah I'm gonna try to think of cop
things but the window this thing is good
oh here's what you gotta do do pull over
chicks and tell them they did something
wrong that's nice
poor note cop yeah I always improv
unsexy dialogue in porno auditions you
do was i speeding no no you ran over
that job yeah I'm trying to think of
good movies though yeah I mean Halloween
was pretty good but Jim didn't like
Halloween was the worst movie that I've
seen so funny it was not scary it was
not entertaining Jim didn't like it cuz
Michael Myers had a beer it was stupid
and they tricked you with that [ __ ]
Danny McBride common pansy Danny McBride
and he did nothing it was nothing you
don't know that Stanley McBride it could
be you know Lauren McBride you have no
[ __ ] where it's not in the movie
yeah but they said he's in the movie
they said he's like of Myers he wrote it
they said he was Michael who said that
go look internet so you just made that
up and did it you might never heard it
but I don't believe people said he was
the man was the old guy with the beer we
saw him without first younger I hated
the disc amber the beer did you see
Bohemian Rhapsody I did pretty good okay
okay not well but I loved you know wild
homosexuality music I'll go watch it
yeah just people having a good time so
you like that Liberace movie why going
through something dude you know trying
to do cocaine heavily and being gay and
sing really I'll write so Liberace you
love that HBO barrage I like the one
with Matt Damon that's the one wasn't
that Scott Thorson he was interesting
but you know what made up anything all
plastic that's a yeah cuz he wanted to
look like Liberace yeah yeah that's HBO
that's not a theatrical release right so
that goes back to your theory every
movie is bad well just a few just I
don't know they're just a lot of strange
movies okay look crazy we can't think of
a lot of good movies gonna tell you this
I saw a trailer for a film yesterday and
a lot of people were talking about it
and when I read what it was I had an
opinion about it
and then I watched the trailer and I
said I think as much as I want my
opinion to remain what it was I think my
opinions changed on this film well the
film is called detective Pikachu and it
is the first live-action Pokemon movie
and the Pikachu is who Nick Nolte is
being voiced by Ryan Reynolds I can see
that interesting right
dead no Ryan Reynolds do you want to see
a little bit of the trailer for
detective Pikachu no no it's about a kid
who's a Pokemon master right or trying
to be I'm sorry it's about a kid who's
trying to be a Pokemon trying to be what
did you just wake up in the morning he's
not a donkey my monster math master and
he meets a Pikachu this is the dark arts
man I'm out of this most of the time
people hear a Pikachu and he just says
pika pika Pikachu right but this kid you
know yeah but this kid can actually
understand a Pikachu and it she knows
what he's saying and that's how we hear
Ryan Reynolds now gyms in yeah nobody
will oh okay that's a good compromise
see ya Pokemon it's a British guy
you know oh who is that
I said Asian guy anything I thought
there was maybe gently no no it could be
Russell Wilson Russell Brand okay work
out see he's not a polka master no yeah
this is mad huh listen you see there's
something going on there's something in
his room what is that I will electrocute
you Oh secrets see he understands the
past longs to new gremlins whoa
maybe the gremlins good it's yellow
gremlins dude which is not a racial slur
either you're adorable
they can't understand me see I like the
idea of a Pikachu like kind of flirting
with a girl and she thinks he's just
being cute but he's you know edgy Ryan
Reynolds cool sounds great hey man you
got to get some adult for exactly
Willard
yeah listen know what you're talking
about right now I just saw the trailers
like kind of interests I'm with you Jim
why do you hate this so much
it's just not my style of film you don't
you know the pokémons is your style it's
not my style of film I'm telling you I
was ready to just think that this was
the stupidest [ __ ] ever look at what's
the one right I don't watch I don't
watch any of the cartoons I don't like
any kids movies and I was like you know
what
dude we're two good movies at I don't
think it's a Madison County yes yes
Dances with Wolves yeah
not long enough you wish it'd have been
a little longer really wasn't enough
Kevin copier you don't think detective
Pikachu is gonna do it then guy maybe
you're right Sam but I can't go I can't
go on this journey with you this feels
like a sham maybe you're right maybe
you're right Roxy you do movie reviews
on YouTube yeah yeah absolutely I'm so
in with you but you're an optimist yeah
look for the good thing
Stefan no I do but this doesn't seem
joyous meant what was it moving lean on
me we grew up on them we're sure her
something's gonna help these place yeah
both of them either one do ya know stay
by me is great well let's just okay
stand by me of course the book was
written by Stephen King sure squat over
me that's my favorite story it's a boy
this is a vagina and anus open at the
same time points out they didn't lay the
number eight I'm talking about
reference for the room state of fact how
old were you the first time you had a
pair of urine-soaked panties shoved in
your face I don't have my panties at my
mouth pissed him when I was like six no
this kid oh wow girl in a bush or
something like that
oh yeah the twins where she she wouldn't
sit on my lap man she was she sat in the
sticker bushes instead of on my lap
naked I said sit on my lap at the
sticker bushes she shot it sound the
sticker bushes how old was that primer
seven and I hadn't heard her brother I
would smell their the pants and they
smell like urine my dad you step this
friend of McGee's he would put cinnamon
in his hand and let us lick it out of it
when I was growing up he was a evil
wanted to molest you guys that's not
sexy letting little kids lick cinnamon
on your hand yes like that's getting a
sexual predator Sheen out of that yeah
trust me he's probably you know what he
probably did after you licked his hand
and left it all saliva II huh
jerked off don't say that I did that
before yeah you know what he did he had
you guys blow him by proxy yeah wouldn't
because it was your saliva why didn't he
use a spoon huh
why didn't he use a spoon it's a great
question who carries cinnamon with no
[ __ ] utensils your spit put this in
your hand
you can get your own here I know I know
he didn't come
you get out of there very clearly see
what he did because he didn't do it he
didn't realize he was on cleanup duty
you guys cleaning all that yeah doing
that I'm not giving you Lube to
masturbate yeah I'm not falling for your
tricks do that and I'm not masturbating
right now not right now we lick your
hand absolutely
so wild man listen yeah Sharon just so
you know this is okay in someone's hand
Roxy yeah what is that guy's gone stand
by me written by Stephen King who also
wrote the book that was turned into the
film which was pretty good
what was it it which came out very
recently no one very good it was decent
you liked that one
I didn't see you man it look kind of bad
miss fine okay go see it but how he was
not good Oh what's like a good movie
that you've seen that you think have
proved the ohon's theory
I think bow wrap Bohemian Rhapsody was
really good I love you call about rap
yeah I see
are you going Hollywood there for a sec
hey I the second it came out I was like
yo you seen Bo rats a terrible thing I
was really mad at myself why did I do
that you ever yeah well you know at
least I didn't say addition instead of
audition okay
I love danfa woman's life itself it's
getting panned but it was really good no
he's the one it is this is us yeah I
love it
[Laughter]
how convenient that you can create a
show where you can kill off characters
to get all the ratings and then the next
week just write them back because people
like them why would anybody watch these
shows
oh this week you can see the episode
where Milo dies next week Milo goes to
the grocery store what are we watching
what are we getting attached also if you
watch like my episode 3 they completely
rewrote the show because they ocular
it's not us anymore okay it's horrible
so good Roxy you know how much I like
you I love you the show you like her
though if you guys ever had any
interactions no I'm a married man Theo I
didn't ask you that part your dirty dog
you looked at her and it seemed wild to
me any kind of notice you didn't know he
feels like we are friends in love with
his wife and has pursued her forever
it's a weird that you've seen the
pictures but here's why I brought it up
because I think that this is us is for
stupid people yeah I can't and that's
why I was trying to be nice with my eyes
because I wanted to Sofitel I don't
disagree with you I think it's also for
the the weak-minded right you like it I
love it okay all right what's a movie
but you can't get him on any other
movies that maybe he's seen you see
first man I never see first man no no I
won't watch it because they took the
American flag out of it
it's not a matter of pride it's just
it's just politically correct garbage
need for that it's a dick move it
doesn't offend me but it's like your
[ __ ] dicks yeah your [ __ ] dicks
you will do that to any other country
that had an accomplishment like that go
[ __ ] yourself I'll get you guys with one
of these California fighters yeah 42
people dead now they said oh really
yeah that's right oh wow that's a lot
dang that's crazy man but you get it
they're nowhere near you know and if
people keep calling me I'm fine yeah
yeah we you know I wish I had enough
money to get burnt out a little place
that you're not in a place that was
burned no no we can't even get I mean we
just got our heater fixed Congrats man
wait a year for your no way huh
yeah I'm also a human being it's getting
winter you know getting winter what is a
winner here it's like yeah it gets
really cool thank you Sam for Boston so
I know yeah okay uh-huh oh we were
disagreeing no you were good huh I like
Polar Express are you bringing up movies
from many years ago when movies were
good Finding Neverland and Butler do you
see black classic great films Landsman
no that was good did you see it or you
didn't like it I didn't see it
okay good it's a good movie yes we had
and he didn't like it cuz he said it
wasn't true yes but he's a communist yes
yes self-define with you really yes oh
wow the guy who did another good movie
thank you for waiting I think is what it
was called it was like that crazy movie
about telemarketers and a black kid and
uses a white voice but then it goes off
into [ __ ]